surprise Beyonce dropped a new single on
us plus Miley Demi Shania it is new
music Friday oh boy how happy are you
guys it's Friday another week has gone
by with three Kardashian pregnancies no
less thankfully there is so much new
music to talk about not Kardashians and
the track that's got everyone buzz in is
of course Beyonce surprise new feature B
hopped on a J Balvin and Willie Williams
hit Meehan pet was a fire track before
but now it's engulfed the remix have got
me feelin a certain kind of way people
Beyonce posted the new music video for
the remix version and wrote that she's
donating her proceeds from this song to
hurricane and earthquake relief oh it's
really cool it seems like she's gotten
her five-year-old daughter Blue Ivy
involved listen closely because many
fans are thinking this is blue singing
along probably auto-tune but it could be
her queen bee and her little girl also
helped those impacted by flooding in her
hometown of Houston and now her and
jay-z's streaming service title will
donate proceeds from their upcoming
Brooklyn concert to disaster relief and
I gotta say again let me hint there
remix is officially on repeat throughout
the weekend people but will we see
Beyonce popping by Saturday Night Live
her husband jay-z will be performing
this weekend during SNL's season 43
premiere fresh off an amazing season
which earn the show nine Emmys SNL is
back with Ryan Gosling as hosts this is
his second time hosting and get this
this year the show will air live
coast-to-coast and let me remind you the
last time Ryan was on he couldn't even
keep a straight face during a sketch
with Kate McKinnon so anything could
happen
alec baldwin will also return to reprise
his emmy winning role as president Trump
we're told he won't have as many cameos
this season due to scheduling and our
own Courtney teza no reason
chatted with longtime cast member Kenan
Thompson on what else SNL has in store
this season how excited are you for this
to come back for SNL to come back I'm
super excited man like you know Lauren
never stops like he's got Ryan Gosling
and jay-z opening the season you know
I'm saying like season 43 is still going
SuperDuper strong with awesome artists
against it's just it's amazing man that
dude that he never stops it's awesome
for real big big big guns
now you know a lot going on in the world
is in politics and pop culture have you
ever thought about the next thing you
want to tackle on Saturday Night Live
that's dealing with the political
climate I'm sure we're gonna be doing
some hurricane stuff probably and
however they respond to it it just
depends man whatever is like going on
probably like that Friday night were
like right up for Saturday show
everything is just so last-minute but
there's so many topics and it was hard
being off all summer you know man so
it'll be nice to get back to it what
something crazy happens we can just jump
right on it all right so let me recap
for you we got SNL Beyonce's magenta
remix all setting us up for a solid
weekend but it's also a new music Friday
and the last of September's album
releases just so happens to include
three awesome butt-kickin women Miley
Cyrus has put her tongue back in her
mouth and returned to her roots and with
her new record younger now the auto-tune
is gone and her voice takes center stage
here's one of my favorites off the album
called weak without you
[Music]
first things first I gather
[Music]
yeah
yo Miley is stripping it back down
people but giving her a run for her
money is Demi Lovato who is back with
her sixth studio album tell me you love
me
chock full of those Demi bangers with
the of course out-of-this-world vocals
but you guys have to check out my
favorite track ruin the friendship let's
ruin the friendship do other things
what's taking us off this time let
through with the friendship let's ruin
the friendship oh I don't know which
friendship she's trying to ruin and he
teased Kelty night even try to get it
out of her tell me about that so ruin
the friendship is a song about having
feelings for someone that you're really
close with and you want to ruin that
friendship by taking the next step and
it's never worth it is it
that's only afternoon Astor yeah don't
give them bad advice not steal not until
you try it do not get to try has it ever
happened to you I don't know I don't
really remember if it has I mean I think
so but yeah this one's a really special
son okay she'll remember if it happened
I'll leave it at that Demi and finally
Canadian queen of country Bop Shania
Twain is back with her first album in 15
years man it feels like a lifetime I'll
see myself out but first you gotta
listen to poor me
[Music]
still campaign
here
[Music]
another faces
all right here's where should I have
told et's nancy o'dell ball why it took
so long to put out another record is
this very coming out ever so many years
it was really scary getting started you
know now that I'm here and I'm through
making the project making the record now
I feel really good and excited about it
I'm not afraid anymore but oh boy was I
ever afraid to get started it really
took a lot of self motivation and you
know forcing myself through so I was
pretty petrified in the beginning now I
think that's part of what took me so
long as well I was procrastinating you
know yeah well the voice was a big I
mean I was I was I was afraid for good
reason I mean I just didn't have my
voice issues under control yet and I was
you know that was one big issue there
was a lot of fear there just knowing
whether I could rely on my voice or not
and if I wanted to really dive into it
you know
start committing myself putting myself
out there in front of people in the
studio and just all of that well you
nailed it Shania and you guys clearly
have plenty to choose from this weekend
let us know who you are listening to on
repeat my lead Emmy Shania Beyonce and
of course be sure to hit that subscribe
button as always stick with ET
online.com I mean just in case another
Kardashian gets pregnant I have a good
weekend guys
[Music]